okay let's go to the 52 senators
so bernie sanders post let's find a post
here
there it is okay so bernie sanders post
about two senators he said two senators
cannot be allowed to defeat the 48
senators and the 210 house members want
what they want
we must stand in the working must stand
with the working families of our country
we must combat climate change we must
delay passing
the infrastructure bill until passing a
strong reconciliation package now
there's a lot to unpack here with mr
bernie sanders uh as you know i
predicted on wednesday that they would
raise the debt limit they did
republicans 15 of them [ __ ] cave
including mitch mcconnell which came out
in front of microsoft's phone said we're
not gonna cave well they caved of course
they did
and and and and mr bernie sanders is
gonna cave here he's gonna cave the 210
members in the house
well
the few progressives in the house that
have this stance that we must delay
passing the infrastructure bill until we
pass a strong reconciliation bill
so until until
now he's he's giving away the game here
in this tweet he's giving away the game
if you read between the lines in
washington speak here what he's saying
is is we want to delay the
infrastructure bill
it's not going to get delayed but we
want to delay the infrastructure bill it
shouldn't be delayed but we are going to
delay the infrastructure bill
to pass the reconciliation package
right and he says we until we pass a
strong reconciliation bill not the
reconciliation bill a strong
because you got to remember these these
people are saying like bernie sanders is
very careful in what he says he doesn't
just type out a tweet and send that
[ __ ] he's not like me i send out
a ton of tweets that have [ __ ]
misspellings in them they're missing
words they look like [ __ ] sometimes
that brian bernie sanders is not me just
[ __ ] flying off the flying off the
handle tweeting right
he's going to be very careful with his
[ __ ] words here
very [ __ ] careful and what bernie
sanders is saying is there's going to be
a compromise on the reconciliation bill
and he is going to vote for it
that's what he's saying and what he's
saying is when we find out what the two
senators want to compromise when we find
that out when we figure that out what
they're going to cut what those two
senators are going to compromise on the
reconciliation bill then we'll vote
we will vote on the reconciliation bill
but there is but he is admitting
admitting that he wants to delay the
infrastructure bill
but there's no reason to
other than to make sure they get a a
secured reconciliation bill that they
can push through reconciliation that the
two senators who are who are holdouts
cinema and mansion
are holdouts of course everyone gives
them [ __ ] for not doing math they say uh
you know let's see here
oh
let's see
let's find some right wingers here
because they're the right wingers
uh here here
here you go
joe cunningham here come on come on god
damn it
joe cunningham here uh let's see who it
as seen on radio so he must be like a
yeah he's with red stage some kind of my
dude it's 52 senators are defeating what
48 senators want so he's saying which is
obvious that there's 52 senators against
the current reconciliation package which
is not completely true
because
kirsten cinema christine kirsten
whatever [ __ ] name is cinema and
mansion
voted for this reconciliation package
they voted for it now not for it but for
it to move to reconciliation and they're
starting to change their minds now the
reason why they're starting to change
their minds is because progresses are
digging in their heels on the three and
a half trillion dollars and that's where
this thing's gonna fall because
yesterday
yesterday joe manchin sent a signal to
joe biden and nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer that hey i'm willing to
negotiate here the hype amendment needs
to be in which is [ __ ] pointless but
it's all theatrics
because you didn't there's a it's a law
you cannot you can't [ __ ] use federal
dollars to pay for abortions which is
dumb but that's the [ __ ] law so the
height amendment doesn't matter that's
all [ __ ] theatrics it's all [ __ ]
that's just that's just so republicans
can say well it was an anti-abortion
bill
that's it we made sure the federal money
did not pay for abortions in that bill
which it's already a thing so that's
that's why they do that so he what joe
manchin's trying to do is is cover his
ass in west virginia that's all he's
trying to do uh chris and cinemas just
acting like a [ __ ] and the reason why
christian sentiment kirsten kristen
whatever [ __ ] name is acting like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] is because she can get
primaried in arizona and she will lose
her seat and the most obvious evidence
is mark kelly won in arizona
and joe biden won in arizona and it's
not because arizona is blue it's because
arizona doesn't have its head up trump's
ass
okay they don't they don't necessarily
like trumpism there it's not a popular
thing in arizona trumpism is not a
popular thing it's an the majority of
people don't want it they don't want
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
they don't want it there that's why
they're so [ __ ] sick and tired of
these trumpers
continuing this audit [ __ ] out there
they're [ __ ] sick of it even the
republicans there are [ __ ] sick of
trumpism
so kirsten cinema is is on the chopping
block here in arizona
so she's just trying to make a power
play it has nothing to do with politics
to her she and she she clearly does not
understand how this is going to work
she's going to vote for this bill and so
is joe manchin he's going to vote for
the bill my guess is and here's my
prediction i told you i'd make a
prediction on this earlier my guess is
this bill ends up being between two and
two and a half trillion dollars the
reconciliation package the
infrastructure package stays exactly the
same it's not going to change uh they're
not going to have to change the records
or the the infrastructure package just
because the infrastructure package has
all but passed
the only thing that's going to change
and has to change at this point is the
reconciliation package that's it
and they're going to throw in things
chris and cinema is going to bend on
this because she is now in a position
where she can't dictate anything and the
reason why is because she's just holding
it up just to hold it up at this point
which is not a thing that is going to
work in the long run it's not going to
work
eventually
there's already a super pac in arizona
that's
gearing up to raise money to [ __ ]
primary her ass
no
but it do do so they're giving bernie
sanders here [ __ ] on the two senators
things that 52 senators is more than 48
senators yeah but it's 48 to 48 and
they're they're working on the two of t
to where that negotiation is going to
fall on the money it's going to be the
amount
the amount is going to be the thing now
why why joe manchin and cinema think
it's better to try to go out and sell a
two trillion dollar package to their
constituents in reelection than a three
and a half trillion dollar package i
have no idea
i think it's a really [ __ ] boneheaded
thing it's really stupid it's they're
they're playing short-term politics here
the long-term politics would tell you
hey we got all this money for investment
in west virginia we got all this money
and investment in in arizona and the
higher that reconciliation package is
the more money they can claim went to
west virginia and went to arizona
and and give some evidence for it
and the people will see it uh because
this the these infrastructure packages
now the roads and bridge package the
traditional infrastructure package is
going to be fantastic for the american
people and the reason why is because
we'll have some decent i mean i don't
know if you guys have driven on the
highways but holy [ __ ] they're not that
great they're just not especially in
these red states and
because they're [ __ ] they they're run
by republicans now you you look at the
reconciliation package and that has
human infrastructure in it not only does
it have health care education child care
it's get a high speed internet i mean
there's a lot of components
to that reconciliation package
that is going to help americans but it's
not going to be three and a half
trillion it's not it's probably going to
be between two and two and a half
trillion dollars that's where it's going
to end up here i believe that's what
nancy pelosi is doing and i think nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer
uh have this thing in the bag that's why
they haven't quite voted on it yet
because they're trying to get in a
position where they can vote vote vote
it goes to biden's death it goes to
reconciliation process it goes to
biden's desk it's done
it's done
they don't want to vote and have it
turned down and have to re-vote they
don't want to have to have mansion and
cinema re-vote on this thing and nor do
cinema and mansion want to have to vote
more than once on this thing
they want to vote once get it over with
and get it through
now
as far as the progressives in the senate
and the house they're making it they're
making it virtually impossible for
anyone to negotiate
because
it was it was no we can't risk passing
the infrastructure bill because they
won't do the reconciliation package
because how they [ __ ] us on 15 minimum
wage and i understand that i understand
that progressives in this country are
pissed off that the 15 minimum wage was
promised and it was pulled and it got
voted and the progressives got [ __ ] on
the 15 minimum wage and they feel like
they're going to get [ __ ] on this
reconciliation package but here's the
thing
all the members they have they have a
solid vote in the house a pretty solid
vote they got a few they gotta get
they're gonna get republicans on this
thing
there is no way that they're not gonna
get republicans in the house to there's
going to be a handful of them because
they're gonna want to say i did that
i gave that money to you
it's gonna happen but kevin mccarthy
isn't gonna release those republicans to
even say they're gonna vote on this
thing until nancy pelosi has her whip
count you got it
they have to have the whip count to pass
the bill before the republicans can be
released to vote for it they're going to
vote on it rather no matter what cinema
and mansion work out on the number that
they want for reconciliation to get the
vote in the senate
how how is it that that
people in this country can't understand
how government works
this is how it works we're watching it
we're watching it work and people are
really upset uh either at mansion and
cinema which that's really where
that's really where the uh
electoral uh punishment should be is
towards especially towards cinema
manchin's gonna vote for this thing
there's no way manchester's not gonna
vote for this thing he's gonna vote yes
on this thing he's going to uh cinema is
the one who's who's not only is she
acting like a fool she's not giving any
reason why she's acting like a fool like
there's nothing she's saying i mean at
least joe manchin is actually
negotiating even in the public in front
of her microphone at press gaggles he's
talking about height amendments and and
the amount that he's willing to settle
for
right
so
bernie sanders though tweeting this uh
i'm not saying he's wrong because bernie
sanders isn't wrong here uh i actually i
actually i'm glad bernie sanders tweeted
this and again the reason why is because
it really it's a it's a really strong
tell of what's going to happen here
i take bernie sanders [ __ ] very
seriously bernie sanders is a serious
[ __ ] person he's not an unserious
[ __ ] person
kristen cinema is an unserious [ __ ]
person
and bernie sanders in this tweet is
actually projecting and telling you what
he sees is gonna happen um and bernie
sanders is no schlub in the senate he's
he's been around the house and the
[ __ ] senate and he's been in the
united states congress and in the united
states government long enough to know
the process here and how this is going
to fall and he's telling you in this
tweet what is going to happen
that's what i see this tweet saying
this is not hyperbole he is telling you
what the [ __ ] he's gonna happen
by the words that he's saying in this
tweet
now there's other things that give me
evidence of what i'm saying but i think
that the the reconciliation bill is
gonna end up being two two and a half
trillion now my opinion is these
progresses need to get off their ass and
just pass the infrastructure bill and
work on the reconciliation package in
the meantime
if if you give if you give cinema and
mansion a win on the infrastructure bill
it might bring them to the table to the
two two and a half trillion where
they're going to fall because again
cinema is going to vote for this thing
she has no reason not to she has not
given any reason not to
she would be stupid not to
because she will be [ __ ] primary if
she does not if she [ __ ] this she is
going if she's the one because joe
manchin whatever whatever reconciliation
bill that nancy pelosi gets back to the
senate joe manchin will vote for it you
hear me
if nancy pelosi votes on a bill on the
house floor it will pass
and that bill will be voted on
by joe manchin he will vote for that
bill whatever the [ __ ] it is that's what
nancy pelosi is going to do that's what
chuck schumer is going to do the wild
card here because she has no [ __ ]
unearthly reason to vote or not vote for
this thing and she cannot she cannot
figure out a reason to or what she wants
because she's not she's not a seasoned
politician here she's not a seasoned
united states senator she thinks just
because she has the power to stall
something she thinks that
she can increase her power
which your you're spending your capital
is what you're doing you're spending
your political capital on this not
increasing your [ __ ] power not in not
advancing your cause you're spending
your capital if you really wanted to
advance your cause you would say out
loud what you want
and if the bill moved in that direction
then that would give you power that
would prove that you have power over the
other senators that would prove that you
have power over the other lawmakers if
the bill moved in the direction you
wanted it to but there's no direction to
move in that's why joe manchin actually
has power here because he's saying what
he wants the bill to move to and the
bill is going to move that direction
because progressives do not want this to
fail
no matter how much they want or how much
they don't want
as far as the amount rather it's three
and a half trillion three trillion two
and a half trillion whatever the number
ends up being i actually believe it's
going to be between two and two and a
half million and the reason why i think
that is because joe manchin said one and
a half million and he's gonna come up
from that number just like democrats and
progressives should have known that the
three and a half trillion number if if
if joe manchin would have balked at this
in the last moments that they were going
to have to cut some of this but let me
tell you something progressives
two two and a half trillion is two and a
half
two or two and a half trillion a hundred
percent
of two trillion if that's what it ends
up being which i think it's again
gonna be between two and two and a half
a hundred percent of two and a half
trillion
is a hundred percent of two and a half
trillion
zero percent of three and a half
trillion is nothing
you got it that's the one reason why
people are frustrated with you dumb
[ __ ] progressives in this country is
because you keep projecting an
all-or-nothing
an all-or-nothing policy and that is not
what the american people want
with the guy here on the screen bernie
sanders they voted against the all or
nothing strategy now he is not tweeting
an all or nothing strategy here that's
not what he's saying
sort of now he's projecting or nothing
when he says we must delay passing
the infrastructure bill right
until we pass a strong reconciliation
bill but he's signaling here hey we need
to change the reconciliation bill to get
it in a situation where we can vote for
both of these he's trying to have it
both ways
and they're they're knocking him on the
two senators thing but the real the real
knock here the real knock here is that
the american people did not vote for all
or nothing strategy they nominated joe
biden who was the opposite in the
primary of the all or nothing strategy
the policy strategy that's why they
voted for joe biden i don't think
everyone loved joe biden and the
democratic primary or the general
election
but joe biden had a message of let's get
some things done even if we don't get
everything we want let's get it done
anyways that was his message
build back better not build back the way
we want it 100 percent
why why can't you fox understand this
and i'm with progressives i i think
progresses play an important role to
pull the policy to the left
but once you pull the policy to the left
you've done your [ __ ] job you've done
your job on policy you don't get to get
a hundred percent of what you want
that's why joe manchin is gonna vote for
this bill
because joe manchin isn't gonna get
everything he wants
he knows that
he knows that now cinema is an idiot she
has no clue she doesn't know what she
wants here
that's why that's why
if if she doesn't
get into a correct policy shape here
she's not going to be the senator of
arizona after her next election
she will probably be primaried
and that primary candidate will [ __ ]
win that race more than likely
because it doesn't have to be a
progressive
to to beat cinema it doesn't have to be
a progressive it doesn't have to be a
liberal it can be a moderate
beat cinema just just by saying
in the democratic primary hey i'll
actually do the things that you vote for
me to do
i won't pretend and then not go do those
things that's all it'll and a record of
that case
to to demolish her in a primary and if
she doesn't realize that at this point
she better get on the ball and her staff
better be yelling and screaming to her
ear if they want jobs
in washington
after after the election in 2024 because
she's got a while to go here
anywho anywho
anyhoos
so
um
i see uh the reconciliation package
coming in at about two two and a half
trillion dollars i think uh it could be
done over the weekend uh i doubt it i
think it'll be uh sometime early next
week
is when they'll come up with it
uh but i think it's gonna come in at
about
uh two two and a half trillion dollars
that's where he's going to come in at
you're going to have cinema and mansion
vote for it you're going to have the
progressives in the house vote for it
because those votes are already being
whipped for that they're pretending that
they're not being whipped because they
don't want to go back on what they said
this all or nothing strategy which is
really [ __ ] stupid that's why bernie
sanders is tweeting this out to keep the
progresses again he's tweeting this out
when he says we must delay passing until
we must delay passing the infrastructure
bill bill until he's trying to keep
progressives in their corner he's trying
to keep him fighting
which it's waning that's why he's
tweeting this it's waning
because there are going to be
progressives that are going to vote uh
the the
nancy pelosi is going to whip the votes
to get kevin mccarthy to release the
republicans because there'll be a
handful of republicans vote for this
thing you'll see it and then you'll have
mansion and cinema release and they'll
vote for the to to move forward the
reconciliation in the senate on two two
and a half trillion it might be up to
three i might be wrong but i think it's
gonna land between two two and a half
so and the american people should take
it we sent you there to get something
not nothing progressives
and cinema and mansion we sent you there
to get something for the american people
it's been a long goddamn time since the
american people have gotten anything
i mean the only thing that a a small
group of americans got when trump was in
office was tax cuts for the one percent
for the richest [ __ ] people in the
country and it [ __ ] the rest of us
it's been a long goddamn time long
goddamn time coming that we need to get
something so
that's the 52 senator thing because it
has to do with the infrastructure bill
well i'm almost at an hour so i'm about
out of time
uh i apologize for not having the
the twitter
feed correct i don't know our